PROFESSOR: Chapter six, problem
set three, problem set
two solutions.
OK.
Good morning.
Nice to see you all again
on this mild day.
I want to start off by thanking
Ashish greatly for
giving the last three
lectures.
I have very high confidence in
Ashish, and I'm sure he give
you excellent lectures and was
able to answer all your
questions, right?
But if you feel dissatisfied at
any point, you'll have an
opportunity to ask the
question again today.
We will continue now
in chapter six.
I understand Ashish got up to
section six point one already,
so that makes my life
a little easier.
And we'll just continue to plow
ahead through the notes.
You have as handouts today
chapter six, the outgoing
problem set, the solutions to
the incoming problem set.
So does anyone have any comments
or questions or
suggestions as we go forward
at this point?
Let's say I'll do a very quick
review of everything so far,
at least what we need to
proceed, so you'll have a
chance to ask questions along
there if you like.
Anyone have anything to say?
Anyone want to say
thanks to Ashish?
All right.
Great.
OK.
So a very quick review.
We first said we were going to
work with a continuous time
Additive White Gaussian noise
channel, but we quickly
reduced it to a discrete
time additive white
Gaussian noise model.
Vector model, Y equals X plus N,
where the vectors may go on
as long as you like.
And implicit in here is we
have some kind of power
limitation expressed
by various --
I know I've probably introduced
too many parameters
in the early part
of the course.
But you'll see them all in the
literature, and I thought you
might as well see the relation
between them all at once.
The noise.
The main thing about this
is it's an independent,
identically distributed noise,
also independent of X, and
it's characterized simply by
its variance per symbol, or
average power.
Again, there are various
notations that we
can use for its power.
OK.
However you express the power
of the signal of the noise,
you're going to get some
signal-to-noise ratio out of
that, as long as you use
consistent the same units for
signal and noise.
And so the key parameters
of this channel turn
out to be just two.
One is the signal-to-noise
ratio.
And the other is something which
in the discrete time
domain we might think of as a
data rate, rho, the number of
bits per two dimensions.
But we were at pains
to show --
and the reason we measure it in
bits per two dimensions is
that it converts directly to the
spectral efficiency, or we
sometimes say, the nominal
spectral efficiency, or the
Nyquist spectral efficiency.
Basically, this is the spectral
efficiency if you
assume that you only use the
nominal Nyquist bandwidth.
And both in 450 and here it was
shown that you can really
get as close to the nominal
bandwidth as you like, its
sharp or roll off as you
like, by using filters.
Very sharp filters or very sharp
digital filters that
today we can really
realistically get effectively
to the Nyquist bandwidth.
So this is a good measure of
nominal spectral efficiency,
which is an extremely important
parameter, the
spectral efficiency in
continuous time.
And then the Shannon limit is
expressed in this very simple
form that we can never do better
in data rate or nominal
spectral efficiency than
log of 1 plus SNR.
And the units are bits
per two dimensions.
So there's an awful lot about
parameters and units in the
first part of the course, and
sometimes it's a little
overwhelming and confusing.
But in my experience in
engineering is, it's extremely
important to get the
units right.
It helps you in thinking
clearly.
It helps you to focus
on the right things.
And so in the first couple of
chapters, there's a lot of
emphasis on getting
the units right.
For instance, bits per
two dimensions.
I could simply assert to you
that things are always to come
out better if you do things
per two dimensions.
This basically has to do with
Gaussian distributions being
simpler in two dimensions than
they are in one dimension.
So you know you can get closed
form integrals in two and four
and so forth dimensions that you
can't get in one and three
and so forth dimensions.
So you know, the geometrical
formulas for the volume of the
sphere and so forth are much
simpler in even dimensions
than they are in
odd dimensions.
This all, I think, has to do
with the fact that really a
one-dimensional complex Gaussian
variable, or in
general, complex Gaussian
variables, are in some sense
mathematically simpler than
real Gaussian variables.
For instance, the Q function
is a very ugly thing.
In two dimensions, you can
closed-form integrals with
probability of error.
So there's a lot of clues that
we really want to think in
terms of pairs of
real dimensions.
All right.
And then we introduced a
couple more parameters.
And I understand Ashish
got the questions
that I get every year.
Why do we introduce both
of these things?
SNR norm, which is SNR
normalized by 2 to the rho
minus 1, that's motivated
directly by the
Shannon limit formula.
Or Eb over N_0, which is
SNR divided by rho.
You know, these are
both more or less
equivalent to each other.
From this Eb over N_0 is just 2
to the rho minus 1 over rho
times SNR norm, so why do we
introduce both of them?
And there's not an
intellectually very strong
argument to introduce
both of them.
Because one is easily translated
into the other.
For fixed nominal spectral
efficiency rho, there clearly
is just a one-to-one
translation.
We could use either one.
If you graph something versus
Eb over N_0 or versus SNR
norm, it's just a matter of
shifting it by this factor.
They're going to be exactly the
same graph with the 0 dB
point in a different place,
according to where 0 dB is.
Philosophically, of course, SNR
norm, which is sometimes
called the gap to capacity, is
exactly a measure of how many
dBs away are we from
the Shannon limit.
Measuring things on
a log scale in dB.
And so 0 dB is always the
Shannon limit point with SNR
norm, because this statement
translates into SNR norm is
greater than 1, which is 0 dB.
So here the focus is always, how
far are you from capacity?
How far are you from
the Shannon limit?
And that really is
the modern view.
In the early days of coding, the
view was, well, how much
coding gain can we get
over no coding?
And as we'll see, Eb over N_0
is often a very convenient
parameter to use when we're
focusing on coding gain.
In fact, for binary linear block
codes, which is what
we're talking about in chapter
six, we get an extremely
simple expression that Eb over
N_0 it's just kd over N, where
N, k, d are the basic parameters
of a block code.
If you don't know those
yet, you will by
the end of this lecture.
And Eb over N_0 is what was put
forward in the early days,
when the principal coding
application was coding for
deep space communications.
It makes sense in the
power-limited regime.
In the power-limited regime,
we showed that this
essentially goes -- this is rho
log2 over rho, so up to a
factor of natural logarithm of
two, these are the same,
almost independent of the
spectral efficiency, as well.
And so this is a very natural
thing to use, especially in
the power-limited regime.
In the bandwidth-limited regime,
as rho gets large,
then these things become
very different.
SNR norm always keeps us in
the neighborhood of 0 dB.
This thing goes up to 10 dB,
20 dB, 30 dB, and so forth.
Nonetheless, you'll see in
some literature, people
continue to measure against Eb
over N_0 maybe I would say,
just because they don't
know any better.
Anyway, since I started writing
these notes about
eight or nine years ago, I've
been advocating SNR norm.
It's more and more widely
used in our business,
in the coding business.
Or equivalently, one always
shows nowadays how far are you
from capacity, and that's
what SNR norm is about.
And you can always translate
this into this and this into
this by this simple formula.
So that's why we introduce
them both.
Eb over N_0 is traditional.
SNR norm is more of the modern
gap to capacity viewpoint.
Any questions about that?
Because I understood that
Ashish got a number of
questions about that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: And the probability
of error you mentioned
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] is natural
with SNR model.
PROFESSOR: Well, this
is a slightly
different point, actually.
So we go on from this to talk
about the power-limited
regime, which we defined more
or less arbitrarily as the
regime where rho is less than
or equal to two bits per two
dimensions, and the
bandwidth-limited regime,
which is where rho is larger.
And at this point, I simply
assert that it's better to do
everything per two dimensions
in the bandwidth-limited
regime and to do everything
per bit in the
power-limited regime.
And the reason for this is
basically long practice and
intuition and experience that
things do work out better, and
this is the proper
normalization.
But I think at this point
in the course, with your
background, this is only an
assertion, all right?
So I simply say, this is the way
we're going to do things
in bandwidth-limited
and power-limited.
For most of the rest of the
course, we're going to be in
the power-limited regime.
Then we'll come back to the
bandwidth-limited very late in
the course.
So you can now forget this
assertion for a while.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, I'm trying
to focus on that here.
That if two systems have
different rhos, then you
should take that into account
in their comparison.
And when you see charts of a
rate 7/8 system, or a rho 7/4
system versus one that's rate
1/8, those are very different
regimes, and it probably isn't
fair to compare two systems,
just in terms of their
probability of error versus Eb
over N_0 at two different
spectral efficiencies.
What is more fair is to compare
them in terms of their
gap to capacity.
You can get more powerful
codes with more
error-correcting capability the
lower in rate that you go.
And so you should start from
the point of view that two
systems with different rho are
incomparable, and then using
this you can say, but, you know,
if we can get within 1
dB of the Shannon limit with
both of them, then they're
both approximately
equally powerful.
That would be the modern
point of view.
But it's really apples and
oranges if they have different
rates, different rhos.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
If [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
systems modulation
[INAUDIBLE].
Then is it fair --
because if one of them
has coding --
PROFESSOR: If none of them
have coding, well --
AUDIENCE: No, just modulation.
PROFESSOR: So what shall
I say to that.
In the power-limited regime,
an uncoded system is simply
binary modulation or 4-QAM,
and there aren't different
systems to compare, really.
There's only one baseline
system.
As you go up into the
bandwidth-limited regime, then
it is fair to compare
systems of the same
class, like M by M QAM.
That's a simple uncoded
system.
Now there, rho keeps changing.
rho equals 2, rho equals 4, rho
equals 6, rho equals 8.
Or you can easily find
intermediate
rates that are uncoded.
And there you find that this
normalization makes all these
systems comparable.
In fact, we saw that we got a
universal baseline curve for
the bandwidth-limited regime,
which was independent of rho,
for, say, the class of 4 by
4, by the class of M by M
bandwidth-limited QAM systems.
I'm sorry.
I got off a plane at nine
o'clock last night, so I may
not be totally coherent today.
But all of these systems have
exactly the same baseline
curve up to the approximations
we've made that their exactly
four nearest neighbors
and so forth.
But on a curve of probability
of error per two dimensions,
per QAM symbol, versus
SNR norm, we
get a universal curve.
So that indicates they really
are comparable.
They form a class where the
performance of the class is
independent of rho.
And that's sort of typical of
the bandwidth-limited regime.
Two systems that differ, that
basically use the same code
with smaller constellation
or a larger-based uncoded
constellation are going to be
directly comparable, and are
probably going to have the
same gap to capacity.
Going to be just as far away
from the Shannon limit.
But we don't have that
phenomenon in the
power-limited case.
Other questions, or
shall I proceed?
OK.
Again continuing what I hope
will be a quick review, but I
don't want to go any faster than
you're comfortable with.
We get this baseline curve
for 2-PAM or 2
by 2 QAM, same thing.
So this is the baseline of Pb of
E on a log scale, where we
typically go down to ten to
the minus six, ten to the
minus five.
Here's 0 dB.
This goes down through
about 9.6 dB here or
about 10.5 dB here.
And the ultimate Shannon
limit is over here.
The ultimate Shannon limit for
very low rho, as rho goes to
0, is about minus 1.6 dB.
And we get expressions.
0 dB is the Shannon limit
at rho equals 1.
At rho equals 2, it's
up about 1.8 dB.
Shannon limit for rho equals
2, and so forth.
And anyway, so we see as a
function of rho, we can
measure the gap to capacity at
different probabilities of
error and see how much
coding gain is,
in principle, possible.
And then for a coded system,
we can put that on here.
The effective coding gain
is the distance
between here and here.
At some target probability
of error.
It's going to differ according
to probably of error.
You found a way of getting a
good, rough-cut estimate, at
least for not very complicated
codes called the union bound
estimate for any signal
constellation in any number of
dimensions.
So if we have a signal
constellation A, which
consists of M points in N
dimensions, so forth,
basically found that we could,
in the power-limited regime,
get an approximate expression
from considering pairwise
error probabilities that's
very simple.
And I used this notation.
Q of the square root of some
coding gain of the
constellation times
2 Eb over N_0.
If it's just 2-PAM then the
coding gain becomes 1.
This is the average number
of nearest neighbors per
transmitted bit.
And so the whole thing reduces
to this expression in terms of
couple of parameters.
the principal parameter is the
nominal coding gain, which is
the minimum squared distance of
A over 4 times the energy
per bit of this constellation
A. So we really only need to
know this kind of normalized
measure of goodness of the
constellation.
And K_b of A Is the average
number of nearest neighbors.
I forget what we call it.
What is the numerator here?
K_min of A, which itself is an
average, over the number of
bits that we're actually
sending, which is log2 of the
size of A.
So basically we only need to
know a couple of parameters of
this signal constellation.
Its minimum square distance
is very important.
Energy parameter, which we
choose to make the energy per
bit, or so that we get
this expression.
And the average number of
nearest neighbors per bit that
we transmit.
OK.
And our best example so far is
the tetrahedral constellation,
where we basically
pick every other
point from the 4 simplex.
Maybe I should do that
in a different color.
I don't think that's
a different color.
Nope.
Anyway.
You know this quite
well by now.
And if we do that, we find that
normalizing everything,
this is 4/3 or 1.25 dB.
And every point has three
nearest neighbors, and we're
sending 2 bits, so
this is 3/2.
So then we get this handy dandy
engineering rule to make
a quick plot of the union
bound estimate.
Given that we decided to put
this on a log-log scale to
start with, all we have to do
to plot this expression --
if we're given, as we always
are, the baseline curve, which
is simply Q to the square
root of 2 Eb over N_0.
How do you convert this
curve to this curve
on a log-log plot?
Well, you simply move it to the
left by the coding gain.
And you move it up by the
log of whatever K_b is.
So if the dominant effect is
moving it left, in this case,
by 1.25 dB --
I'm going to wind up getting
about this curve, so I won't
draw it again --
then we move it up by a factor
of 3/2, we developed a rule of
thumb that said a factor of two
is basically going to cost
you about 0.2 dB.
Around ten to the minus five.
This is just based on the slope
of this baseline curve,
as long as we're somewhat
in that region.
So this will cost us about 1/10
of a dB, so we'll get an
effective coding gain
of about 1.15 dB.
So graphically, we take
this curve bodily.
We move it over 1.25 dB,
and we move it up
by a factor of 3/2.
And what we'll find is the
effective coding gain is
thereby reduced to, I estimate,
about 1.15 dB.
And this is all just engineering
rules of thumb.
Nice template.
I sometimes say you should
fill out a copy of this
baseline curve, cut it out, put
it in your wallet for the
duration of this course,
because you'll have the
opportunity to make
this kind of
calculation again and again.
All right.
So that's union bound SNR.
For simple constellations,
the union bound
estimate is very accurate.
So this is a very good way to
proceed, from an engineering
point of view.
We want to write a paper?
You know, it's a little late
to write a paper on the
performance of the four simplex
signal constellations,
but if you wanted to, and you
wanted to have one graph in
that paper, you would
have the graph of --
well, you would actually
probably compute the exact
error of probability, either by
analysis or by Monte Carlo
simulation, you would
put that in there.
But in your first draft of the
paper, you would put in union
bound estimate and you would
find that wasn't far off.
OK.
Any questions on that?
This has basically got
us up to chapter six.
So in chapter six now, which
Ashish got into last time.
This is basically about binary
linear block codes.
And well, we first just
start talking about
binary block codes.
That's what Ashish
did last time.
We basically take 0 and 1
as our binary alphabet.
We take a blocks of length n.
Sorry.
Are we using little
n or big N?
Little n, where n is called
the block plank.
So we take the set of all binary
symbols of length n,
and we're going to convert
this to real n space.
How do we convert it?
Component-wise, by the
standard 2-PAM map.
We map 0 into plus alpha,
1 into minus alpha.
So this maps into plus or
minus alpha to the n.
So the entire universe of
possible code words that we
have is this set of 2 to the
n real n-tuples, which are
simply the vertices of an
n cube of size 2 alpha,
obviously, right?
Just like this.
We have eight possible
vertices in 3-space.
They obviously all have
the same power.
They all lie on the surface of
a sphere of squared radius n
alpha squared.
So they're not only the vertices
of a cube, they're
vertices that are spread on
an equal energy sphere.
And the whole idea is that our
code is going to be some
subset of this, and the code
will map under the same map,
which we call S, into
some subset of the
vertices of the n-cube.
OK?
And again, our favorite example
is the tetrahedron.
For instance, if we take the
code as being 0, 0, 0, 0, 1,
1, 1, 0, 1 1, 1, 0, those for
binary three-tuples, this maps
into T, the tetrahedron.
OK?
Well, we get this signal
structure, which we've already
found the coding gain.
It has a little bit
of coding gain.
We actually accomplished
something.
All right.
So that's the basic idea that
we go through in 6.1.
That's our favorite example.
And Ashish also shows you that,
you know, you might
think this is an awfully
restricted way of designing
constellations.
But when we're talking about low
spectral efficiencies, by
going through the capacity
calculation, we can assure
ourselves that in principle,
this is not going to be very
sub-optimal for it.
Capacity is about the regime
where n gets very large for
very long block codes.
We don't lose much in potential
coding gain, or in
the Shannon limit, equivalently,
by restricting
the input output input alphabet
to be just these two
numbers, plus or minus alpha,
I should say, rather than
using the whole real line as
an input, as long as the
nominal spectral efficiency is
less than or equal to one bit
per two dimensions.
And the exact numbers --
at rho equals 1, you lose about
0.2 dB, in principle,
using the Shannon limit
as your guide.
And for lower rho, it
just goes to 0.
And you did this last time.
OK.
So it's a very reasonable, and
obviously attractive from an
implementation point of view,
way of designing signal
constellations.
And again, this is basically all
we're going to be talking
about for the majority of
the course, is signal
constellations like this.
But of course as we get to codes
that are thousands of
bits long, or perhaps even
infinitely long, as in the
case of convolutional codes and
trellis codes, sometimes
you forget that we're really
talking about just putting
points in Euclidian
signal space.
Because we're going to be very
abstracted back into the
binary domain.
But in this course, we're always
thinking of codes as
means of designing signal
constellations.
Of course, codes are used far
more widely than just for
signaling over the additive
white Gaussian noise channel.
I've sort of packaged this
course as a search to get to
capacity, we have added
the additive white
Gaussian noise channel.
First of all because
this corresponds
very closely to history.
Within this package, we can
talk about all of the
principal classes of codes that
have been developed to
date, and we can compare them
in some performance terms.
How close do they get to
capacity on the additive white
Gaussian noise channel.
So you get most of what you
would get if you took a
communications-free view
of coding theory.
You know, people are interested
in codes for
computer memories, for
God knows what,
lots of other things.
And for many of these other
applications, you are going to
be interested in the same
class of codes.
Basically, you're going to want
to maximize the distance
between code words for a given
rate, which has to do with the
size of the code.
And so you're going to be
interested in the same codes.
Putting it in the framework of
getting to capacity on the
additive white Gaussian noise
channel gives a motivation,
gives a very nice story, because
over 50 years, we were
able to get to capacity,
and gives it a real
communications flavor.
Some of you, I'm sure, are here
without any interest in
communications whatsoever.
You simply want to know
about coding.
You will still get that story,
but you'll get it
in this nice package.
That's why I do it this way.
OK.
I'm about to get
into new stuff.
End of review.
Any questions?
So you must have done
a great job.
Everyone understands
perfectly.
All right.
So now let's talk about,
as I said, binary
linear block codes.
When you see the word "linear,"
that's a signal that
there's some algebra ahead.
And so this is the very first
point at which we get into
what's called algebraic
coding theory.
The algebra will be extremely
simple at this
point, not to worry.
And what are we doing here?
First thing we do is to identify
0 and 1 with the
binary field, which I'm always
going to write as F2.
The older way of writing this
is GF(2), for Galois field
with two elements.
They mean exactly
the same thing.
Nowadays most people
write just F2.
Now we have [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
we can write this blackboard
F.
And OK.
Step one.
We've identified our alphabet
with a field.
So algebraically,
this is a field.
Some of you know exactly
what I mean by that.
Others don't.
We'll come back to this again.
Informally, I would say a field
is simply something
where you can add, subtract,
multiply, or divide.
Our best examples of that before
now have been the real
and complex fields.
There is a more formal
definition of that.
In this case, we have
only two elements.
So let me just write down the
tables, which you all know,
regardless of your background.
What's the addition table
for this field?
Well, 0 is the additive
identity.
So we know that 0 added to
anything gives itself, so that
gives us three of the entries
of this table.
What do we put down here?
There's really only one choice
to satisfy one of the axioms
of the field, which is that
under addition, the field must
form a group.
In particular, that means that
all elements are invertible.
That means that each row or
column has to be a permutation
of the group elements.
And so the only possibility
here is to put in a 0.
And well, we are forced, if
we're going to make 0 and 1
into a field to find an addition
table which is the
table of mod2 addition.
You've had this stated
as an axiom before.
You can derive it just from the
fact that 0 needs to be
the additive identity, and then
we need to put a 0 in
here in order to get
invertibility.
Under multiplication.
What is the multiplication
table?
Well, the additive identity
is also a nullifier under
multiplication in any field.
So 0 times anything
is equal to 0.
1 times anything is
equal to itself.
So that completely determines
the multiplication table.
Again, just the table of
mod2 multiplication.
So if I'd done this
axiomatically, I would have
given you the axioms of field.
Then I would show that under
this binary addition
operation, this multiplication
operation,
we satisfy the axioms.
I'll do that as we get
into chapter seven.
OK.
So now we have 0 1 to the n,
n-tuples, binary n-tuples, we
will now regard as n-tuples
of field elements, F2.
And these will be regarded as
vectors in a vector space.
Well, I'll just say that F2 to
the n is a vector space, which
clearly has 2 to
the n elements.
Now again, informally.
What's a vector space?
A vector space is always
over a given field.
In this case, it's going
to be over the
binary field, of course.
F2.
The given field is
called a scalar.
Just like vector space over
the reals, the scalars are
real numbers.
Here the scalars are
elements of F2.
And what do we have to have to
make something algebraically a
vector space?
We have to have that the
addition of two vectors is
well-defined and gives another
vector, and that the
multiplication of a vector by
a scalar is well-defined and
gives another vector in
our vector space.
All right?
OK.
So how are we going to define
that to addition?
If we want to add
two n-tuples --
again, you aren't going to see
anything here that you haven't
already seen in some
other context.
What do we do?
We add them component-wise,
using the component-wise rules
of field addition.
OK.
So we just add two
vector n-tuples,
component by component.
We obviously get some result,
which is itself a binary
vector or an F2 vector.
No problem there.
Except that --
well, all right.
As long as we're talking about
all possible n-tuples, the
result is certainly in the
vector space, right?
We add two binary n-tuples,
we get a binary n-tuple.
So the result is
in F2 to the n.
This is going to be the key test
when we get to subspaces
of F2 to the n.
OK.
And multiplication
is even easier.
How do we define multiplication
by scalars?
Well, we only have
two scalars --
0 and 1.
So 0 times any vector is going
to equal the all 0 vector.
Again, you can view that
as just component-wise
multiplication of everything
by 0, and since 0 times
anything equals 0, we're
always going
to get the 0 vector.
All right?
So is the 0 vector in
the vector space?
Well, yes.
If we're talking about several
n-tuples, it of
course always is.
And one times anything, again,
we can just do this
component-wise, and it
just gives itself.
Trivially.
So since this was a vector in
the vector space, this is
certainly a vector in
the vector space.
OK.
This seems pretty
trivial so far.
But what's a binary
linear block code?
Again, focusing on the
linear, is a --
now I'll give a formal
definition.
it's a subspace of F2
to the n for some n
called the block length.
All right.
What do I mean when
I say a subspace?
I mean subsets of the elements
of a vector space that itself
forms a vector space.
So in this case when I
say subset, I mean a
set of binary n-tuples.
OK?
That itself forms
a vector space.
OK.
What are the components
of that?
To check that it forms a vector
space, let's see.
Multiplication by scalars is,
again, easy to check.
If it's going to be a subspace,
then the all 0 --
so it has to contain the all 0
vector in order that when I
multiply by the scalar
0, I get another
element of this subspace.
Multiplication by 1 is always
trivially satisfied.
If I start off with a set, I
multiply by 1, I'm going to
get the same set.
So let's check whether the
elements of a subspace are
closed under vector addition.
What do I mean by that?
I mean if you add two elements
of the of the subspace
together, you get another
element of the subspace.
That's the key property
to check.
Key property -- we can
write that as closure
under vector addition.
Which is also called
the group property.
It means that just under
addition, under vector
addition, the set of elements
that you have forms a group.
You add any two elements,
you get another
element of the subset.
The example is our favorite
example so far.
Let's take this little code,
and I'm going to ask.
Is that a subspace of
F2 to the three?
So does this equal subspace
of the set of all binary
three-tuples?
Anyone care to hazard a guess
whether it is or isn't?
AUDIENCE: It is.
PROFESSOR: It is?
Why?
AUDIENCE: It has the
all 0 vector.
PROFESSOR: It has the all
0 vector, first of all.
Good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And it's closed
under addition.
Now how might we see that?
You could, of course, just
take all pair-wise --
you could form the addition
table of these four elements,
and you would find that you
always get another one of
these elements.
For instance, 0, 1, 1 plus 1,
0, 1, is equal to 1, 1, 0.
In fact, you easily see that you
take any two of these, add
them together, you get
the third one.
If you call this a, b, and c,
a plus b plus c equals 0,
addition is the same as
subtraction, because we're in
a binary field.
So that means that a plus b
equals c, a equals b plus c, c
equals b plus a, whatever
you like.
And of course, if you add 0 to
anything, it's trivially
closed under that.
All right.
So it is.
It satisfies --
it's all you've got to check.
A more abstract proof of this
would be, this is the set of
all even-weight three-tuples.
If I add even to even, I'm
going to get even.
So of course my result is
going to be another
even-weight three-tuple,
therefore in the set.
That's the more algebraic
proof.
All right.
Suppose I just add 0, 0, 1
to all of these things.
I'll get the set of all
odd-weight n-tuples.
Add any odd-weight
n-tuple to this.
Let me take the C prime,
which is the set of
all odd-weight n-tuples.
Is that a vector space?
It doesn't have 0, and in fact,
it's not even closed
under vector addition.
All right.
If I take in C double prime is
equal to 0, 0, 0 0, 1, 1, 1,
0, 1 and I stop there,
is that a subspace?
No.
Because?
Not closed.
For instance, if I add these
two together, I would get
that, and that's missing.
OK.
So actually, everything is
much simpler when we're
talking about finite fields.
All the finite dimensional
vector spaces consist of a
finite number of elements.
It's easier than real and
complex vector spaces.
There's no analysis involved.
So forth.
All right.
So a binary linear block
code is in a subspace
of F2 to the n.
What are some of the key
algebraic facts we know about
vector spaces from our study
of linear algebra, which I
assume all of you have had
in some form or another?
What's a key algebraic property
of a vector space?
What's the very first
property?
All vector spaces have a --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Norm?
No.
Dimension.
Dimension, that's
where I'm going.
What's the significance
of dimension?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The definition of
dimension is the number of
generators in any basis.
So we're talking about
generators of the vector
space, or a set of generators
which form a basis.
If you think we have the same
properties here in the case of
vector spaces over finite
fields, well, we probably do.
But let's see how
it works out.
So we're talking about
things like
generators, basis, dimension.
These are all closely
interlinked properties.
Again, the fact that everything
is finite here
gives us very elementary
ways of addressing
all of these concepts.
We don't have any
geometry yet.
We don't have norms.
We don't have distances.
We don't have angles.
We'll talk about that
in a minute.
Here we just have a set that
basically has these two
properties.
It contains the all-0 vector,
and it's closed
as the group property.
It's closed under
vector addition.
All right.
So the first property is that
the all-0 vector is always in
the subspace, which I'll
represent by C, meaning code.
So when I talk about a code
now, I'm talking about a
binary linear block code,
which by definition is a
vector space, a subspace
of F2 to the n, where
n is the code length.
All right.
Let me try to find a set of
generators for the code.
All right?
If somebody gives me a code,
they say, this is a binary
linear block code.
Let me see if I can find a
set of generators for it.
If I find three generators,
then I'll know the
dimension is three.
That's basically where
I'm going.
I'll state this a little bit
more formally as we go ahead.
So suppose I'm given a code.
I know it's a binary linear
block code, so I know it has
the all-0 element.
So how might I go about finding
a set of generators?
Let's just take a greedy
algorithm.
All right?
Suppose the code contains
only the all-0 vector.
Is that a subspace?
What's its dimension?
0.
All right?
So that's a very trivial vector
space, but it's a
vector space.
Satisfies the axioms.
Suppose it is not the
trivial code.
That means it has more than
the all-0 vector.
So I take as my first generator
any non-zero vector.
OK?
I can always do that.
Don't have the axiom of choice
involved here, because
everything is finite.
So I'm going to take g1 to
be any non-zero vector.
Now I've got a generator.
And how many code words
does it generate?
I want to take the set of all
binary linear combinations of
all the generators that
I have so far.
At this point, the binary linear
combinations are 0
times g1 and 1 times g1 And that
just gives me this word
and this word.
So now I have counted for two
words with one generator.
Could it be that that's
the whole code?
Sure.
The all-0 vector and any
non-zero vector together form
a one-dimensional subspace.
That's all you can get
from one dimension.
So I could be finished
here now.
But if I'm not finished, there's
still more code words
that I haven't accounted for.
Then I greedily pick
a second generator.
So this is now, let's say, any
vector not generated by g1.
So I have a branch here.
Either I've finished or I can
pick another generator g2.
Now with g1 and g-two, how many
vectors can I generate?
Let me take all binary
linear combinations.
So a binary linear combination
is any vector of the form
alpha1 g1 plus alpha2 g2 where
these are both scalars.
And therefore this can be 0 or
1, this could be 0 or 1.
So what have I got now?
I've got 0, g1 g2 and g1 plus g2
I've got four binary linear
combinations of two
generators.
Could that be the whole code?
Certainly.
At this point, again, consider
our standing example.
I start out what I take
as my first generator.
Let me take g1 equal 1 0, 1, g2
equals whatever, 0, 1, 1.
Then if I take all binary linear
combinations of these
two generators, I'm going to
get the whole code, right?
These four code words.
They can all be expressed
in this form.
Or I'm not done, and then
I have to pick g3.
And how many binary linear
combinations are there of g1,
g2, and g3?
Eight.
Are they all necessarily
in my subspace?
Yes, by the fact that the
subspace is closed under
scalar multiplication.
Alpha g1.
Alpha1 g1, alpha2 g2 alpha3 g3
are all in the subspace.
Any vector addition of any of
these scalar multiples is in
the subspace.
So I get now eight possible
elements of the subspace, and
I either may be done or not.
Continuing in this way, I get
some number gk of generators,
just by picking greedily the
next one until I'm done.
All right?
When I'm done --
so I have to stop.
Why do I have to stop?
All right.
Let's look at the size.
At each point here, this
accounts for two code words,
this for four, this for eight,
this for 2 to the k.
How many binary n-tuples
are there?
2 to the n.
All right?
So I clearly can't find more
than n generators.
More more than n independent
generators, in the sense that
the set of all the
binary linear
combinations are distinct.
All right.
So k is, at most,
going to be n.
So I will stop in a finite
number of steps.
I'll stop at some number k.
When I've stopped, that's
because the code consists of
all binary linear combinations
of these k generators, and
therefore has size 2 to the k.
So the only possible size of a
subspace is 2 to the k for k
less than n.
A power of 2 where the
power is, at most, n.
So any subspace besides
the subspace --
I'm repeating myself.
OK.
So this means I found a basis.
Does this mean that all possible
bases of any subspace
have the same size?
Well yeah, it must.
I mean, I've proved now that any
subspace has to have this
size 2 to the k for some k.
So obviously, if I go through
this process, no matter how I
choose my generators, I could
choose any pair of these
non-zero n-tuples as
my generators.
So that would be a
legitimate basis.
Take any two out
of these three.
But it's always going to take
exactly two of them, right?
Why?
Because the size of this
subspace is four.
Two to the two.
So if I go through this process,
I'm always going to
come up with k generators, where
k is the log to the base
2 of the size of this code that
I was given, which I was
told was a linear code, meaning
it's a subspace.
So I'm somewhat free to choose
the generators, but I'm always
going to come up with k of
them if the code has
size 2 to the k.
So a basis is a set of k
linearly independent k-tuples,
where linear independence has
the same meaning here as
you're accustomed to, meaning
that all linear combinations
of the k generators
are distinct.
So I get 2 to the k distinct
elements of the code.
And I say the dimension
of the code is k.
In this case, basically it's the
size of the code is 2 to
the k, then its dimension
is k.
Has to be.
And all basis have k
generators in them.
And there are, in general,
many ways to pick them.
All right?
So just by considering this
greedy basis construction
algorithm, I basically find the
size of any subspace is a
power of two, and the power
is equal to the dimension.
And any basis is going to
have that cardinality.
Are you with me?
This is a pretty simple proof.
And I call this an n, k binary
linear block code.
n being the length.
That just means that every code
word is an n-tuple over
the binary field.
And k is the dimension.
So an n, k binary linear block
code has size 2 to the k.
That's 2 to the k distinct
code words.
Main example is this guy.
Easy?
Any questions?
I think this is clear.
AUDIENCE: Can n use the number
of code word, I take
like 2 to the k?
PROFESSOR: n is something I
specify a priori as the length
of every vector in the code.
In other words, it has size 2 to
the k, and it's a subset of
the set of all binary
n-tuples, which
I write like that.
In other words, the
elements of the
code are binary n-tuples.
If I write them out, each
one has length n.
OK?
We're good?
What are some other examples?
The simplest codes you can
think of is, first of
all, an n, 0 code.
That means a code with dimension
zero, has size what?
1.
And what does it consist of?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this is the so-called trivial
code, just containing
the all-0 word.
Has to mention 0.
It is a binary linear block
code, but it's not much use
for communication.
So but nonetheless, we include
that in this family.
Another trivial one is n, n.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: F2 to the n, right.
What's its size?
2 to the n.
That means it has to contain all
distinct binary n-tuples.
So this is called the
trivial code.
This is called the
universe code.
Contains the entire universe
of binary n-tuples.
Let's get some slightly
less trivial ones.
n, 1.
What would that be?
An n, 1 code.
What's its size?
2.
What does it consist of?
The 0 word, and?
Any other non-zero generator.
And that's correct.
This can be 0 and any generator,
two words.
In communications, where we want
to maximize the distance,
in some sense, between the
two code words, what is g
always taken as?
0,1's, right.
So if it's in particular the
all-0 and the all-1 word,
which I might write as a vector
of 0's and a vector of
1's, this is called the
repetition code.
The binary repetition
code of length n.
It either gives me a 0 and I
repeat it n times, or gives me
a 1 and I repeat it n times.
So whenever you see n,1, you
can pretty well assume it's
the repetition code, though
it might be any pair 0, g.
And n, minus 1.
This is an interesting one.
Again, while this could
be a lot of things, in
communications, whenever you see
this, this will always be
the set of all even-weight
n-tuples.
In other words, the set of all
n-tuples with even parity such
that if you sum up all of
the components of any
vector, mod2 equals 0.
OK?
So this I will call the single
parity check, or more briefly,
the SPC code, or the
even-weight code.
That's equally good.
And here we maybe should do
a little bit more work.
Say, is this in fact
a subspace?
Does it include the all-zero
code word?
Yes, all-zero has even weight.
The sum of any two even-weight
code words, an even-weight
code word, an even-weight
n-tuple.
Yes.
As here.
This is an example.
This is the three,
two SPC code.
OK.
Why is this dimension
n minus one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Is every code word orthogonal
to the one-vector?
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's an excellent answer.
It's a little advanced
for us right now.
I'm looking for an elementary
argument.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you're saying we have
a set of generators
that looks like this.
Is that what you're saying?
You are correct.
And how many such generators
are there?
There are n minus 1 of them.
I always like to find the most
elementary argument possible.
I think the most elementary
argument here is that the
number of even-weight n-tuples
is equal to the number of
odd-weight n-tuples, and
together they form the set of
all n-tuples.
So exactly half of the n-tuples
are even weight.
That means there are 2 to the n
minus 1 of them, 2 to the n
over 2, and therefore, the
dimension must be n minus 1.
But perhaps this is just
as elementary a proof.
Well, however you do it, you'll
find that there are 2
to the n minus 1 of them, or
that here is clearly a set of
generators.
It might take a few more lines
to show that every even-weight
code word is a linear
combination of this particular
set of generators, but
it's certainly true.
All right.
So these four classes of codes,
these two entirely
trivial ones, these two which
are actually somewhat more
interesting for coding
purposes --
we've already seen, we can get a
coding game with this length
three, dimension two code --
are basically the simplest
codes we can think of.
The simplest binary linear
block codes.
Now we'll see them
again and again.
They turn up.
All right?
So the whole course is
going to be about
finding 1's in between.
More complicated ones.
There's clearly more
room to play.
For instance, if k is equal to
half of n, which means that
rho is equal to one bit per two
dimensions, there's a lot
of possibilities.
And so we're going to explore
those possibilities.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sure.
Let's take the 6,5 code
generated by these five
generators.
Well, it contains some
odd-weight code words, obviously.
But it's not as interesting from
a coding point of view.
It's not the only one,
but it's the only one
you'll ever see here.
All right.
Let's see.
One thing I didn't point out
in the notes but probably
should have here is, what is rho
for an n, k binary linear
block code?
How many bits can we send?
Suppose we take the Euclidean
image of this.
It is going to have 2 to the k
points, 2 to the k vertices of
the n-cube, and so
what is rho?
What is the rate in bits
per two dimensions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
The rate is basically k over n
over 2, if you like, or 2 k
over n bits per two
dimensions.
You can send k bits in n
dimensions, or 2 k over n bits
per two dimensions.
And since k can't be larger than
n, this is going to be
less than or equal to two
bits per two dimensions.
So again, we see we're
definitely in the
power-limited regime, and that
we can really get any nominal
spectral efficiency between 0
and 2 by choosing k and n
appropriately.
All right.
So n and k determine the rate,
determine the nominal spectral
efficiency.
All right.
Let's now talk about things that
I think are also very old
hat to you.
I mean weight and distance.
But we begin to get into areas
that show us that these vector
spaces are very different from
the real and complex vector
spaces that we're
accustomed to.
So what are we doing now?
We're starting to get into the
geometry of this vector space.
The geometry is not Euclidean
geometry, but
it's Hamming geometry.
We define the Hamming weight
of a vector as simply the
number of 1's in v. So the
Hamming weight of the all-0
vector is 0, the Hamming weight
of the all-1 vector is
n, and in general, the Hamming
weight is somewhere
between 0 and n.
Just the number of 1's.
Pretty simple.
And given two vectors x and
y, what is their distance?
The Hamming distance between x
and y is equal to the Hamming
weight of x minus y.
This is the standard way of
converting a weight metric
into a distance metric.
Or because addition is the
same as subtraction in a
binary vector space, we might
equally well write this is as
the Hamming weight
of x plus y.
And more informally, this is
simply the number of places in
which they differ.
OK.
So if x and y are identical,
then x plus y is equal to 0
and the distance is 0.
If they are complementary, y is
the complement of x, then
they differ in every place.
The sum will then be the all-1
vector, and the weight, the
Hamming distance, will be n.
And so again, the Hamming
distance is somewhere between
0 and n, measures how
different they are.
Clearly going to be important
for coding.
It's going to translate directly
into Euclidean
distance under this standard
2-PAM map.
OK.
Again, let's check that it
satisfies the distance axioms.
I don't know how many of you
have seen this, but let's see.
What are the distance axioms?
Strict non-negativity.
In other words, the Hamming
distance between x and y --
that's a single comma --
is greater than or equal to
0, and equality if and
only if x equals y.
That's what strict means.
So if we find the Hamming
distance is 0, we can assert
that x equals y.
We have, of course, symmetry.
The Hamming distance between
x and y is the same as the
Hamming distance between
y and x.
Order doesn't matter.
And finally we have the triangle
inequality, that the
Hamming distance between x and z
certainly can't be more than
the Hamming distance between
x and y plus the Hamming
distance between y and z.
If x differs from y in only n1
places, and y differs from z
in only n2 places, then clearly
z can't differ from x
in more than n1 plus
n2 places.
So check, check, check.
This is a legitimate metric for
defining a geometry on the
space, and this is the one that
we use on the space of
all n-tuples.
But notice it's not all like
the Euclidean Distance.
Now when we have a
linear code --
let's combine these things.
When we have a linear code, we
have a group property which
is, let me write it this way.
If we take any code word and add
it to any other code word,
that's in the code.
And furthermore, c plus c prime
is not equal to c prime
plus c single prime, c
plus c single prime,
because we can --
well, I'll finish it.
Unless c prime equals
c double prime.
Why is that?
We can do subtraction,
cancellation.
Cancel c out from each side.
So if we add c to c double
prime, we're going to get a
different result from adding c
to c prime, if c prime and c
double prime are different.
So this implies that
c plus C --
I write that as an abbreviation
for the set of
all c plus c prime, as a c prime
runs through the code C.
So this is the 2 to the k sums
of the code plus any code word
in the code.
Sorry if I don't write
down all steps.
What is that going to be?
C. How did we conclude that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Perfect.
Did you all hear that?
By the group property,
each one of these
things is in the code.
By this argument, no two
of them are the same.
That means I get 2 to the k
distinct elements all in the
code, that's got to be the code,
because the code only
has 2 to the k elements.
All right.
So if I add a code word --
in other words, if I write
down the code --
0, 0, 0, 0, 1, 1, 1 0 1, 1 1 0-
and I add any code word to
it -- say I add 0
1 1 to the code.
So let me just do one column
of the addition table.
I get 0, 1, 1, 0, 0, 0,
1, 1, 0, 1, 0, 1.
I'll get the code
itself again.
This has a very important
property.
The set of Hamming distances C
and c prime, as c prime runs
through c, from any given code
word C, it is independent of
C. So I can start from any code
word, measure the Hamming
distances, the 2 to the k
Hamming distances to all other
code words, including
C itself --
let c prime run through the
entire code, I'm going to get
a set of 2 to the k distances
called the distance
profile of the code.
And I claim that it doesn't
matter which code
word I start from.
I'm going to get the same
distance profile regardless of
where I start.
In other words, the set of all
distances from the all-0 word
here, which is 0, 2, 2, 2, is
the same as the set of all
distances from the 0,
1, 1, code word,
which is 2, 0, 2, 2.
And the proof is basically
that this is simply the
Hamming weight of C plus c prime
as c prime runs through
C. What is this equal to?
So the proof is that this is
equal to the Hamming weight of
c prime as c prime
runs through C.
So the distance profile from any
code word is simply equal
to the weight profile
of the code itself.
The weight profile of this code
is 0, 2, 2, 2, Start from
any code word, measure the
distances to other code words,
I'm always going to get
0, 2, 2, 2, 0, to
itself, and the others.
Sounds sort of like the
tetrahedron, doesn't it?
It's zero distance from a code
word to itself and equal
distance to all the other
code words, in
that particular case.
OK.
So again, everything is
very elementary here.
The distance profile is
independent of C and equal to
the weight profile.
So this has an extremely
important corollary.
What's the minimum Hamming
distance of the code?
You might expect this
is going to be an
important code parameter.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The minimum Hamming
distance between any two code
words is going to
be equal to --
I think you said it.
AUDIENCE: The 0
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Non-zero
is important here.
If the distance profile is equal
to the weight profile,
one of the weights is always
going to be zero.
And that corresponds to the
distance between a code word
and itself.
All right.
If I go through all the other 2
to the k minus 1 distances,
they're going to be weights.
They're going to be the
distances from a code to all
other code words.
And the minimum distance is
simply going to be the minimum
non-zero weight of the code.
For example, in this code, the
minimum Hamming distance
between any two distinct code
words is going to be equal to
the minimum distance from
the 0 code word --
that's another way
of doing it.
Since it's independent of C, we
may as well take the base
code word C to be zero.
And then what's the minimum
distance to 0?
To the 0-code word?
It's the minimum weight.
From the 0 code word, distance
equals weight.
So the minimum distance is the
minimum weight of any non-zero
code word, which for
this code is two.
Now here the weight profile
is 0, 2, 2, 2, 0.
The distance profile from any
code word to all the others is
0, 2, 2,2 2.
This is always the distance
to itself.
So minimum distance to
other code words is
always going to be two.
Furthermore, the number of
nearest neighbors --
to go back and use chapter
five terminology --
the number of nearest neighbors
is going to be the
number of code words that have
that minimum weight --
in this case, three.
Still sounding a lot like
a tetrahedron, isn't it?
This easy map between Hamming
distance and Euclidean
distance for this case and in
general for all of our cases.
So corollary.
The minimum Hamming distance,
which implicitly means between
two distinct code words of C,
is equal to the minimum
non-zero weight of C, and the
number of minimum weight code
words is independent --
I'm doing this backwards.
From any code word, the number
of code words that distance,
let's call this d, is equal
to the number of
weight d code words.
Sorry, you probably
can't see that.
All right.
So we get this symmetry property
for codes that
follows from the group property
of the code that if
we stand on any code word and
look out, we're always going
to see the same thing.
We have this constant.
It's actually easiest to see
this when we make the map from
the code to the Euclidean
image of the code.
So the Euclidean image S of C
of the code word is going to
be some set of 2 to the
k vertices of an
n-cube of side alpha.
Let's talk about the Euclidean
image of these properties.
If the minimum Hamming distance
of the code is d,
what's the minimum squared
Euclidean distance between
elements of S of
C going to be?
Well, let's do it coordinate
by coordinates.
Let's take two code words,
C and c prime, let's say.
And let's suppose we have
some Hamming distance
between C and c prime.
That means that c and c prime
differ in the Hamming
distance, number of places.
So if we map this into the
corresponding pair of vertices
of the n-cube in Euclidean
space, S of C and S of c
prime, how many coordinates are
these going to differ in?
It's going to differ in same
number of coordinates, D_h.
If they don't differ, what's
Euclidean squared distance in
those coordinates?
0.
If they do differ, the Euclidean
squared distance is
4 alpha squared.
So the Euclidean distance D_e
between S of C and S of c
prime is simply going to be
4 alpha squared times the
Hamming distance between
C and c prime, yes?
So I should say this is the
squared Euclidean distance.
Why do we always talk about the
squared Euclidean distance?
Because it's additive,
coordinate-wise.
And the Hamming distance is
additive, coordinate-wise.
So there's a nice
easy map here.
So what does this mean d_min
squared is going to be?
d_min squared of, let's say, S
of C. This constellation that
we've formed by taking the
Euclidean image of c.
The minimum square distance
between points in S of C is
just going to be 4 alpha squared
times d, where I don't
think I ever --
d equals min Hamming distance.
And we're always going to talk
about n, k, d as the three key
parameters of a binary
linear block code.
n is the code length, F2 to the
n, k is the dimension, d
is the minimum Hamming
distance.
So by going into this Hamming
geometry, we've got a third
key property of the code.
And we see it's key, because we
can get the minimum squared
distance between this Euclidean
image constellation,
just 4 alpha squared d.
AUDIENCE: nd makes
a probability of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] that is
dependent on [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
then.
PROFESSOR: Correct.
This is all we need to know to
get the union bound estimate.
Well, a few more things.
We need to know what K_min
average of S of C. And what is
that going to be?
This is simply going to be the
number of words in the code.
To get this minimum squared
distance, we need a Hamming
distance of d.
So the number of words in the
code of distance d, which is
given by the parameter n sub d,
is simply going to be the
number of nearest neighbors.
Not just the average distance,
but I want to emphasize this
symmetry property.
If we stand on any point, on
any vertex of this cube in
n-space, which is the code
vertex, and we look at all the
other points in the
constellation, no matter which
point we stand on, we
will always see the
same profile of distances.
We'll see precisely nd code
words at Euclidean distance 4
alpha squared d.
We'll see nd plus 1 at Euclidean
squared distance 4
alpha squared d plus 1, and so
forth, right up the profile.
So there's complete symmetry
in the constellation.
In that universe, you don't know
which code point you're
standing on just by looking out,
because the world looks
the same to you.
Is that clear?
OK.
So from a communications point
of view, this is important,
because it means it doesn't
matter what code word we send.
The probability of error from
any code word is going to be
the same as the probability of
error from any other code
word, because the geometry
is exactly the same.
The Voronoi regions are
all the same shape.
So given the exact probability
of error, not just the
union-bound estimate, is going
to be independent of which
code word was sent.
This all follows from the fact
that it's a linear code and
therefore has the group
property, which translates
into this very strong
geometrical uniformity
property in Euclidean space.
Or actually in Hamming space
too, but it's more striking in
Euclidean space.
OK?
So we have everything we
need to write down
the union bound estimate.
Union bound estimate was just
the probably of error per bit
is well approximated by K_b of
constellation, in this case, S
of C, times Q of the square root
of the coding gain of the
constellation times
2 Eb over N_0.